[Music]
all right so I've been trying to reach a
million followers on Instagram for quite
some time now
wax the whole body do for the Instagram
followers
guys right and I failed every single
time
I only got a hundred followers again no
Paul I failed this time but guess what
I'm gonna find something else I just saw
this girl go viral on Instagram because
she runs and jumps like a horse
[Music]
I think I can do that so I'm gonna go to
the office and try this out
[Applause]
[Music]
okay um it was animal like animal like
we're getting there that's that's good I
don't know what kind of handle okay a
bear no what do I need to do to be more
horse like hey okay that's a good time
[Music]
it's like an angry horsey yeah those
that are like
you're not Kosovo not even a little bit
slow motion gallop do you want to go for
it dear just try it I do not know that
was pretty good wasn't really that was
the first attempt I think so okay you
practice for maybe next couple hours I'm
gonna go keep shooting all right so I'm
gonna go interview some people how to
park because I feel like people at parks
have seen horses before because they
like nature so let's go see if people
have any good advice do you mind being
in a video real quick oh sorry I didn't
mean to scare you you guys have horses
in Australia there's a lady doing yoga I
feel like you need to be flexible for
this so I need to ask her I feel bad
bothering her but okay have you seen
this new viral horse running trend no I
haven't I mean she's obviously talented
doing that so good honor if you can run
on four legs okay yes you know this girl
and the point is I have no idea she just
likes doing it what do you think of that
[Laughter]
I'm gonna try it right now I want to see
honest opinion here hold the mic
[Music]
I appreciate the effort but as the lease
horse like running I've ever seen I
think at the end you need to tuck that's
all I need my trollop looks good yeah
your trial is great you have like great
stride you your height is perfect it's
just in the landing you could be a
little bit more graceful what advice do
you have for it to look more horse like
um I would just quit I wouldn't try to
become a horse you want to try it I
believe in you man you look like you
could do it he's promised freely you can
do anything it's a bit of pressure on
your body the whole body feels it I look
like an idiot
all right so I'm getting mixed reviews
some people are saying I got it some
people say I suck I don't feel very
confident I feel like it's sloppy I look
like anything but a horse so I'm gonna
try and get in touch with the actual
girl and see if she can help me hey
what's up good good how are you thanks
so much for calling how did you discover
it that you had this talent or like this
is something you enjoy doing
well I said a horse riding ten years ago
so me and my friends would jump around
after horse lessons and then years later
some people on Instagram that would also
jump so I got inspired by them and I
made my own account and started
practicing more often what's the highest
jump you've ever done but all four legs
the highest of jump that's sweet foot
ten on two legs my highest jump is four
foot ten do you think that someone like
me can get pretty good at this in a
short period of time oh yeah of course
I've seen like seven year old girls I
can jump all this as high as I can
really
oh yeah is it like feet and hands
simultaneous or is it kind of like a try
that's a diagonal pair so my front left
hind right move simultaneously and my
other two legs move independently our
producer in the back is just trying to
figure that out real quick how to do
that I think I just need to work on just
making it look a little smoother and
then the jump how do you jump yes I'm
gonna take off with your feet side by
side and kind of press up with your
diving tuck your arms up pin it close to
your chin and then land with your hands
all right so next steps I'm gonna go get
some comfy clothes and master this
yeehaw
okay so what does it look like right now
what do I need help with some rhythm
[Applause]
that's honestly closer
oh you stride faster so like more like a
horse come on that's faster does that
look right okay so now I'm gonna go for
the jump that's pretty high huh so the
cone is up to my thigh and I'm about six
speed so it's pretty tall
[Music]
[Music]
I think I did it that was absolutely a
was it really there was I'm like a horse
now right pretty much yeah all right so
last night I ended the video of me doing
the horse jump the soundtrack is Old
Town Road which i think is hilarious I
uploaded at Instagram and now I'm going
to check how many followers I got in 24
hours let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
leeks and ponds and country song little
sweet home - probably powers and laughs
guitars backyard BBQ we're gonna Monday
friends on fighting